welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and spider-man 3 has been giving us
more and more clues pointing to this
movie's mysterious
plot i'm talking mysterio himself
confirmed two factor into this story
and there's actual evidence this time
that we can all look at instead of us
having to take the word of some scooper
with his inside sources aka whatever
we'll get the fans most hyped
i'm gonna explain what these new clues
are everything we are learning about
this third spider-man film and how it
all connects to what we already know
about this story spoiler warning in case
i'm right so from the set of this third
spider-man have come
all kinds of new looks tom holland is
peter parker on a snowy new york street
the movie is confirmed to be a story set
at christmas it looks like mj's working
in a bakery peter pan donut and pastry
shop which at first has some christmasy
decor in the windows but
in a closer later angle mj has put up
some hanukkah at once too but the
crucial detail was spotted on
a poster wall plastered with missing
persons flyers
and then these two peculiar finds an
image of mysterio with
i believe and then further down in the
corner citizens to defend spidey so
there's a lot to unpack here first this
confirms our theory from spider-man
apart from home that
whether or not mysterio quentin beg the
man is dead
something by the way that remains very
much up for debate since peter failed to
work his question to edith properly
is this real all illusions are down
peter mysterio is bigger than one man
people
it's a whole team of disaffected stark
employees
and community theater actors working
collectively to pull off these illusions
as we saw when mysterio's footage was
downloaded to a flash drive and then
later in the post-credits scene when
mysterio's doctored footage framed and
doxed peter
team mysterio lives on fully capable of
ruining peter parker's life with a
deadly trickle of fake news propaganda
and that is what we are now seeing with
this mysterio poster
the rise of conspiracy theories in the
mcu people making mysterio into a kind
of martyr
and it's not just the helmeted visage of
the character this is gonna be a big
deal because another poster
shows the face of jake gyllenhaal and
while that still doesn't mean he'll
physically appear in the film
it does confirm that they care enough
about this subplot to at least pay
gyllenhaal
some appearance fee and to credit him in
the movie which they have to do if they
use someone's likeness this is also
consistent with clues we spotted in
morbius which while less of an mcu
property and more of a splunky one
is expected to be loosely connected to
the mcu spider-man with a crossover from
michael keaton adrian toombs and
background graffiti labeling spider-man
murderer sony did delay morbius but only
to october
signaling that they still really need
this movie to come out before spider-man
3 in december
now of course spider-man isn't a
complete public enemy there's this whole
other campaign
citizens to defend spidey it's much
nerdier name i'm guessing a small
operation headed up by like ned or mj or
flash
we do know he's a big spidey fanboy to
be honest i'm a bit more concerned about
all these
missing posters feels like something you
would see right after the snap
not on the other side of the blip once
the avengers brought everyone back
what is causing all these people to go
missing a new killer on the loose in
manhattan
or some multiverse crisis causing
individuals to disappear from this
reality
and others from alternate realities to
suddenly appear in this one
in fact if such a crisis is gripping new
york in this whole world
that could explain why the public is
embracing mysterio
who claimed to be a warrior from another
dimension within the multiverse
in their eyes an avenger type hero who
really could have helped them in such an
event
there are multiple realities peter this
is earth dimension 616. i'm from earth
833.
you're saying there's a multiverse
because i thought that was just
theoretical i mean that completely
changes how we understand the initial
singularity we're talking about
an internal inflation system and how
does that even work with all the quantum
focuses
even though mysterio was totally lying
there kevin feige has suggested peter's
excitement for the idea of the
multiverse from this scene
and the idea that doctor strange is
going to be in this movie according to
feige those two things are going to tell
us a lot about where this movie is going
and now with mysterio we are starting to
get a much clearer picture of what is
going
on and this video is brought to you by
inline audio and their mod mic
microphone
so the mod mic allows you to turn your
favorite headphones into a headset
instantly you just attach a mod mic to a
pair of headphones or a vr visor any
other kind of flat-ish surface
this thing is great for pc gaming and vr
you can actually put the modmic wireless
on wireless headphones and stand 30 feet
away from your webcam during a zoom call
with your family and still sound way
better than grandma
because you know she loves to scream
into that microphone and you will sound
better because this
is a serious mic with way higher quality
audio than the headsets that are a lot
more expensive
it's got noise canceling and studio
quality modes in a really really
convenient quick mute button
the mod mic wireless has 12 hours of
battery life and you can charge it while
you're using it having an antlion mod
mic cuts down on
clutter on your desk and it's just
convenient for travel it's a great way
to
upgrade your audio experience while
still showing off those cool headphones
that you love so much
so go to antlionaudio.com new rockstars
and use the promo code new rockstars to
check out to get 15
off upgrade your audio now get
incredible audio quality with mod mic
the world's first ever attachable
microphones that's antlionaudio.com
new rockstars or just click on the link
below and make sure to use the code new
rockstars to get 15
off your order so how does this mysterio
propaganda campaign and the missing
persons posters fit in with everything
else we know about spider-man 3. well we
know that doctor strange will join the
plot along with alfred molina doc ock
and jamie fox electro last seen in
totally alternate universe spider-man
films meanwhile everyone from toby
maguire andrew garfield willem dafoe
kirsten dunst
emma stone to charlie cox matt murdock
daredevil from the netflix series
have been rumored to appear by various
scoopers with varying degrees of
reliability but
none of these have yet been confirmed a
big we'll see on the rest of those
either way it is clear sony's goal is to
bridge this
mcu spider-man with elements from past
films and alternate universe within the
spider-man brand to create a kind of
live-action spider-verse
these mysterio posters set the stage for
that conflict
following far from home peter parker
continues to face scrutiny from team
mysterio who might have
pre-recorded several contingency tapes
designed to ruin spider-man's reputation
in the event they failed in europe the
thing is this detached
leaderless crew of special effects
experts would struggle to maintain an
effective media campaign without help
some of that help could come from
j-jonah jameson's daily bugle site but i
think they would need
bigger backing to truly turn public
opinion against an avenger so i think it
is possible that team mysterio is being
backed by
oscorp who think about it would now be a
weapons tech rival
to stark industries eager to have gotten
their hands
on the late tony stark's edith tech and
their whole satellite-linked drone fleet
if those defoe rumors are true that
could be how we get norman osborne as a
corporate villain and maybe a silent
partner to this
assault on spider-man's public image and
when the media campaign doesn't work
norman osborne might decide to
escalate to an actual team of people to
take spidey down and that's how we get
the assembly of the sinister six
vulture electro doc ock maybe morbius or
scorpion or
carnage or team mysterio all over seen
by
norman osborne green goblin now here are
where things get a bit tricky because on
one hand the inclusion of all universe
actors like alfred molina and jamie foxx
might suggest that these villains
origins could be from
a kind of multiverse crossover of
villains they pop in through some kind
of multiverse collision
or through a portal of some kind but on
the other hand we have heard it
suggested that sony might make these
villains
not the same exact forms that they were
in those past movies
but like a different doc ock a different
electro
guys that have just always existed in
the mcu just
played by the same actors for some
reason that muddy
approach is kind of what they did with
jk simmons j jonah jameson like hey
look it's the saint j jonah don't that
nostalgia feel great
uh but wasn't his peter parker tobey
maguire
shut up nerd this don't have to make
sense pretty solid amy pascal impression
whether these sinister six villains are
given multiversal origins in the film
or if sony shrugs it off as if it just
makes sense for them to have already
been
in this reality as these actors i think
doctor strange in this movie represents
marvel studios in kevin feige's solution
to that madness
and within the movie peter parker's
solution to the sinister six crisis
because the best way for peter to face
so many villains
is for him to team up with doctor
strange to navigate the multiverse to
find
allies other spider-men from alternate
universes
that's how they could get toby and
andrew in there and really justify
doctor strange's role in the story
because what are they just bringing him
in so he can do the winds of watoom no
he's in there because he knows his way
around the multiverse so the sinister
six backed by norman osborne versus
team spidey backed by the sorcerer's
supreme i mean even sony couldn't ruin
that i
am wearing our new latest obsession
shirt an unusual couple
it's amazing and it has secret easter
eggs revealed via augmented reality
you can get this shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram
eavos follow new rockstars and subscribe
for breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you